Olá, pessoal. Aqui é o Dr. Alan e hoje
vamos responder uma pergunta que eu
recebi no Instagram. Alfa GPC ou CDP
Colina para autistas? Mas
especificamente eu vou destrinchar para
vocês a diferença entre Alfa GPC, CDP
colina, porque essa confusão tá
prejudicando muita criança por aí. Há
cerca de um mês, atendi uma mãe. O filho
de 6 anos autista tomava suplemento de
colina há meses e ela não via nenhum
resultado. Quando olhei o frasco era
colina bir tartarato comum. Gente, é
como tentar encher um balde furado. A
colina não estava chegando no cérebro da
criança. Mudamos para Alfa GPC. Em três
semanas o menino começou a formar frases
completas pela primeira vez. Lógico,
isso não é garantir que todas as
crianças autistas vão ter o mesmo
resultado, mas de qualquer maneira é
muito recompensador. Eu vou te contar
uma realidade que poucos falam. Estudos
recentes 2024 mostram que entre 60 a 93%
das crianças autistas têm alguma
deficiência de colina. E isso não é
coincidência, pessoal. A colina é o
combustível da acetil colina, um
neurotransmissor que coordena memória,
linguagem e processamento sensorial.
Exatamente. As áreas mais afetadas no
autismo. Mas aqui vem o pulo do gato,
que a maioria dos profissionais não
sabe. Nem toda a colina é igual. Imagine
que o seu cérebro é uma festa VIP e a
colina comum é aquele cara que fica na
fila do lado de fora. Já o Alfa GPC,
esse entra direto, sem fila e sem
burocracia, atravessa barreira em mata
encefálica, como se fosse o dono do
lugar. Vamos aos números que realmente
importam. Alfa GPC tem 40% de colina
ativa por peso. CDP Colina tem apenas
18%. Isso significa que para ter o mesmo
efeito você precisa de mais que o dobro
de CDP Culina. Mas não para por aí.
Existe um estudo específico que poucos
conhecem. Pesquisadores testaram 400 mg
de alfa GPC por dia, durante 8 semanas
em 20 crianças autistas de 3 a 8 anos. E
os resultados? Melhora significativa em
funções cognitivas e reações
comportamentais. Agora vou te explicar
uma coisa que mudou minha visão
integrativa sobre o autismo. A
cetucilcolina não é só sobre memória,
ela regula o transporte íons, potássio,
cálcio, sódio, que são fundamentais pro
processamento sensorial. Sabe aquela
criança que não suporta barulho, que tem
crises com textura de comida? Muitas
vezes a deficiência de acetilcolina
atrapalhando esse sistema de filtros
neurológicos. CDP colina tem as suas
vantagens também. Eu não vou ser
injusto. Ela fica no organismo 60 70
horas, enquanto GPC fica apenas de 4 a
se. Então a CDP colina é mais com aquele
remédio de liberação prolongada e ela
ainda se quebra em uridina que ajuda a
construir membranas celulares. É
interessante para casos de longo prazo,
mas na prática clínica com autistas GPC
ganha disparado. Primeiro porque o
efeito é mais rápido e perceptível,
fundamental paraa adesão das famílias.
Segundo, porque crianças autistas
frequentemente têm dificuldade de
absorção intestinal e alfa GPC contorna
isso melhor. Uma dica que eu uso na
clínica, eu costumo começar com 200 mg
de alfa GPC duas vezes ao dia para
crianças menores, 300 mg duas vezes ao
dia para maiores, sempre longe das
refeições para melhor absorção. E aqui
vai um aceite. Se a criança tá tomando
melatonina, eu dou o alfa GPC pela manhã
e tarde, nunca à noite, senão pode
interferir no sono. Tem pais que
perguntam: "Doutor, posso dar os dois
juntos?" Não recomendo. É como misturar
energético com café. Excesso de
acetilcolina pode dar náusa,
irritabilidade até piorar alguns
comportamentos. Na abordagem funcional,
menos é mais quando falamos de
neurotransmissores. Uma coisa que me
impressiona é como a indústria
farmacêutica ignora esses suplementos.
Alfa GPC, medicamento prescrito na
Europa, mas aqui no Brasil é só
suplemento. Isso dificulta acesso e
padronização de qualidade. Por isso,
sempre oriento, procurem macas que têm
Alfa GPC real, não aquelas misturas
baratas que não fazem efeito nenhum.
Crianças autistas têm alteração no ciclo
da meteonina que interfém na produção
natural de colina. Por isso,
suplementação aqui não é luxo, é
necessidade básica para esses cérebros
funcionarem direito. E tem mais,
pesquisa de 2024 mostrou que colina na
gravidez pode reduzir risco de autismo.
Mães que consumiram pelo menos 480 mg
durante a gestação tiveram filhos com
menor incidência de transtorno do
espectro. Isso reforça como essa
deficiência vem de berço, literalmente
pro dia a dia das famílias. Minha
sugestão é clara, alfa GPC para
resultados mais rápidos e perceptíveis,
especialmente linguagem, comportamento
social. CDP Colina poderia ficar como
segunda opção, mais para manutenção a
longo prazo ou casos específicos onde
queremos efeito prolongado. Uma última
observação importante, colina trabalha
melhor em conjunto. Vitaminas do
complexo B, especialmente B6, B12 e
folato, potencializam os efeitos. E aqui
entra visão funcional. Não tratamos
sintomas isolados, tratamos o sistema
como um todo. Então, resumindo para
vocês, se seu filho autista ainda não
usa colina, tá perdendo uma ferramenta
poderosa. Se já usa colina comum ou
betartarato, considere migrar pro Alfa
GPC. E se já usa Alfa GPC, mas não vê
resultado, revise a dosagem e horários
pode estar errando na estratégia. Saia
do vídeo agora se você gosta de ficar no
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não existe filtro que
eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso em minha clínica. Casos de
reversão que parecem impossíveis,
combinações ofel que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. Lives semanais
respondendo perguntas PDF com mais de 47
protocolos exclusivos e grupo do
WhatsApp. Se você quer a medicina
funcional real sem simplificação para as
massas, clique em seja membro. E não é
para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados. Yeah.